[Music]
so let me say it again cam i may be a
superhero but i'm also just a man who
fell in love with the wrong woman he's
the man who fell for the wrong woman uh
for the wrong one but out of crisis
comes changed
i am very excited for everyone to meet
the real me
there's something wrong with homelander
or something broken
he's lost his [ __ ] mind
we've been on the straight and narrow
all year
no killing soups no drinking
even follow hugh campbell's orders
without strangling him
now you're just being cruel or maybe
you're not such an [ __ ]
people are superpowers
but real power isn't this
it's the ability to bend the world to
your will
[Applause]
the gloves are off
i thought we could fight about the right
way but we can't it's all rigged we have
to do it your way
we're all we've got
it's up to us
i think i have something
[Music]
maybe we can use it to blow homelanders
[ __ ] brains out
what's this makes you a soup for 24
hours
you're gonna need it
[Music]
the whole point of what we do is that no
one should have that kind of power
for once i level the [ __ ] playing
field
i show people
the real
me mean they [ __ ] loved me
[Music]
christ soldier boy
[Music]
you